BRING STAR POWER TO CHIST GOINGE
TUNNEL AT LEAST.
STAYING ON THE SHARKS BENCH.
SASHA CHMELEVSKI, TOE DRAG,  THE
THROWS UP.
GOOD OPEN POSITION FROM
CENTERING NOAH GREGOR AND
RUDOLFS BALCERS. SAVE.
ASSUMING WITH ALEX DeBRINCAT,
40-GOAL SCORER, AND IF THEY KEEP
PATRIC
HASN'T BEEN A QUICOEWS, AT
DOORSTEP, JOHNSON TRYING TO DeB.
BACK ACROSS, AND IT HITS
TH 76278
ALL THE ANALYTICS FAVORED
CHICAGO IN THE FIRST PERIOD.
SHOT ATTEMPTS E PACE IT NOW, PRD
BY RADDYSH, GIVES IT AWAY.
SAM  WIDE.
>> Bret: McCABE PUSHES ON TH>> T
BACK FOR MEIER FOR
BARABANOV, BACK FOR TIMO AND HE
SCORESE WINS THE STICK
BATTLE RIGHT THERE
SHUFFLES I HAVING TROUBLE
KICKING IT BACK TO THE STICK,
THAT'S IT FOR THE POWE CONTINUEY
SHARP AS THE SHARK WORKS IT DEEP
SIDEE FONET.
BUT WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE
WHAT WE GET THE LAST 2 BORDELEAP
KID, AND
GREGOR GAVE A SHOT BACK TO
JOHNSON, AND TYLER JOHNSON IS
GOING TO THENOW, AND
HE'LL
SHOOTING THE PUCK A LOT MORE
BONINO GETS THIS, THINKI
REVERSES IT TO HIS PARTNER, HE'S
GOT TIME THEN TO FIND DeBRINCAT
BACK FROM MELOCHE, THREADSWKS L
STICK IN THERE
PUCK